If his measured weight is 800 N at rest, that must be his true weight,
because at rest, the normal force is equal to the weight and so both are equal to 800 N.
If his target weight is 600 N, that's what he wants the scale to read.
That's how hard he wants the scale to be pushing up on him that should be the normal force.
Well, now we can do F=ma.
For F, we'll plug in where 800 is 200 bigger than 600, so we have an unbalanced force of 200 N.
M is going to be 80 and that's because this 800 N. That's equal to mg and g is 10.
If I divide both sides by 10, m is 80, so if 200=80a. a=2.5 m/s².
And how far will this elevator travel in 5 seconds if this is its acceleration?
Well, we can use this equation, which we know from unit 2.
We assumed it started from rest as soon as your velocity is 0.
And that gives us a Δy of about 31 meters. Good job.